if you already made a decision to become
an entrepreneur but you don't know what
to do next today in this video I will
give you a five-step process for you to
become an entrepreneur the evolution of
becoming an entrepreneur and you can
make a decision for yourself on which
route you want to go to so before I get
into the five step let me first talk to
you about different industry sectors
route services you can take to becoming
an entrepreneur because it's not the
great thing about wanting to become an
entrepreneur it's not one-dimensional
there are multi dimensions of becoming
an entrepreneur and I'll share with you
which route I took but there's many
routes so as I go through all of these
here with you you need to ask yourself
what sparks you may be a 17 year old
watching the st. boom that sparks let me
or make a list of three then investigate
those three and choose one of the routes
and give ten years to it so now you know
you may be a 32 year old and you're
saying I've already made a decision
which one I'm going to but how do I make
a decision to take you to the next level
I may talk about that at the end of this
video so first let's start off with the
top left financial this is the route I
took
I started off with different ones but
this is what I connected with the most
now for you financial could be many
different things it could be somebody
selling memorabilia I know somebody who
sells hundred thousand dollar baseball
cards or more that's what they do they
just sold one card for 1.5 five million
dollars at 1.15 million dollars it was a
Mickey Mantle 1952 Topps baseball card
PSA I think it was nine that's sold for
1.15 old PSA eight that so for that much
money
that's memorably maybe art as financial
insurance stocks real estate artwork
whatever it is that's our Paul the
financial Forex commodities that's
financial many of consulting you could
be somebody that helps with strategy
we're going to come in and help your
business put a strategy together take it
to the next level lower you're still
consulting IT consulting marketing
advertising CPA that's all part of
consulting services could be your
personal trainer car wash uber a
cleaning pools haircut that service
because I can cut my hair myself but
maybe I'm not going to do as good of a
job as you are you're next but not
come to not pay two twenty dollars in
exchange for you to do it as an expert
because I don't want to do so I'll give
it you that is in exchange for service
that you're providing the hospitality
could be a restaurant hotel bar
nightclub you may say man I just love
bar I grew up in it with my family I
want to go and find a way to make a real
cool bar and that's what I want to do
restaurant my mother's got this most
incredible recipe and what if we can
turn it into a business right inventor
could be research and development it
could be technology you can invent the
next table that turns around into a
whole different thing and you turn
around color changes all these other
things you can do as an inventor then
you have nutrition which is health and
fitness you can take the nutritional
route the gym rod medical route you may
like that you may go want to find the
cure for cancer you may want to go out
there and open up a gym and what makes
your gym very cool is it's a gym
combined with a library and hey matter
of fact that may be an incredible idea
right there for you to be thinking about
I'm going to open up a gym and I'm going
to add a bookstore to it can you imagine
you're selling buying books on this side
then I'm going to go lift weights so
after my workout I have a smoothie or
something and there's books I want to
buy next thing I'm buying two or three
books that's your niche you want to do
gym and something else at the same time
manufacturing cars computers clothing
you like clothes you want to go certain
brand expertise language you speak
multiple different languages you want to
take that to the next level electrical
plumbing software coding fashion you see
fashion in a different way where people
look at you and you just know how to put
it together then you have entertainment
entertainment could be graphic design
movies dancing editing music writing
acting makeup
you're just you're all about
entertainment and that's fascinating to
you agriculture could be farm equipment
Natural Resources oil and obviously some
of these things connect with other ones
that we have here but you can pretty
much choose by the way there's some done
not even put in here on the board
because we would need a ten times the
size of this board to have it on here
but you get to pick and choose which one
you want to go with for me one of the
things I notice happens a lot is the
newness mentality which is a big mistake
for some veteran entrepreneurs which
means what they made a decision to be in
one they've been in it for five to ten
years all of a sudden saying I want to
try this not want to try this not want
to try the non
this thinking that's the real issue or
the challenge but you got to choose one
and stick to it for ten years so now
let's just say you watch this and he
said okay how to become an entrepreneur
I connect with this I connect with this
I connect with this great what do I do
next five steps choose one route one
route choose one route to go find a
place to work for you're not an
entrepreneur yet but go find a place to
work for and learn from somebody that
knows exactly what they're doing
three become an expert at that one thing
so for instance you're going to
insurance you learn under a company
let's just say you got a job you're
working under Northwestern Mutual I'm
just throwing a name out there then from
there you decide to go somewhere where
it's you know you you learn under a
great producer and you learn how to do
all the stuff that he's learning and
then you become an expert at insurance
you go work in a hotel restaurant and
you work from the bottom you become a
you know busboy and then you become a
hostess then a waiter then you become a
restaurant manager then you move up in
the restaurant they say man this is
exciting I want to run a restaurant I
want to run a restaurant within a very
massive chain I want to go to Europe and
do all this other stuff whatever it is
step number one choose a route number to
work for somebody that knows what
they're doing and work your way up three
become an expert for four find a way or
two to make it better find a way or two
to make it better so you're going to
write things down there so I would do it
much better if we did it this way once
you find a way to make it better then
become a leader either in the company or
part of where you have a voice and ask
to own a piece of the company or earn to
have a piece of the company or two if
they say no leave and go to another
place where you can own a piece of the
company or become an entrepreneur that's
the route you can pick and choose how to
get to that route very simple choose a
route work under somebody can learn from
them become an expert make a list of how
you would do it better next become a
voice and a leader ask to own a piece or
a piece if that doesn't work go to
another place where you can or start it
yourself and become the entrepreneur
throughout the entire time because I get
a lot of people that tell me things like
hey Pat I have this great idea and and
what do I do with this great idea have
with the company because I want to
become an entrepreneur but I don't have
any money so how do I become an
entrepreneur
almost every entrepreneur I know worked
somewhere made some money save the money
then they started a business that's how
it works it's not just I've never ran a
business before I've never had a job
before I've never done anything before
can you please give me a half a million
dollars there's an evolution you got to
get through to becoming an entrepreneur
now obviously there are many different
routes just like a relationship you can
meet somebody and you marry them out of
church somebody else meet some on tinder
somebody else meets them on line
somebody meets them on Facebook somebody
meets another party somebody meets them
at a bar there's many different routes
that you can but when it comes down to
entrepreneurship this step that I told
you the five step happens to be the most
common way for you to become an
entrepreneur and eventually build a
business become successful make a ton of
money for yourself and have fun doing it
so with that being said Polly why don't
we throw the pillow out here I think I
forgot one other point right I think I
forgot one other point to add on my top
right my top left your top right there's
three ways you can sell these products
one is face to face then I think it's
online then I think it's phone call
should be right up here yes face to face
online phone call you will pretty much
figure out how you can sell these
products you can sell face to face I'm
going to come sit in front of you and
sell it to you I'm going to sell this
product online or I'm going to sell this
product through fawn whatever way it is
you try to find a way to do it better
anyways you got any questions about this
comment on the bottom if you have not
subscribed Paul this is an older pillow
Polly so we got it we got a new pillow
week we got you know what Paul why we do
this when we do this a little bit
different show me do we pick down one
right while we show off give me three of
them give me the top three here's one of
them that we like oh you're so funny
make it we had a record apologist it and
only Paul would spill something like
this just turn it around Mario I hope
you see this because Mar you always give
Paul a hard time for be honest and not
water it's protein shake Paul man Paul
he's got it
things like that okay here we go here we
go here we go okay so this year's from
Sarah Shabana which by the way this is
probably the most comfortable you know
that the quality Sarah I don't know I
got to give you some love here this
feels amazing this is from Sarah Shabana
was top three then we have one from
Billy Wilson which we love Billy
Wilson's let's put a picture of Billy
Wilson's the the bird he gave to Kansas
State when he dropped out in USA Today
and Huffington Post everybody wrote a
story about him and he said I dropped
out after watching a video stay in
school or drop out on value team and
this is from Billy Wilson Billy cannot
wait to see a rocket in the world of
entrepreneurship
you got the fire to pull it off I'm
looking forward hearing your success
story this is from Billy but we didn't
choose it at first place first place
goes to this one here Jennifer max
pillow value taemin 1 million subscriber
is the goal Jen Mac thank you for this
pillow and for the rest of you that are
watching we have a lot of other pillows
that we got here but these were top 3 if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
please do so if you got any questions
about this you can snap me but when you
snap me please do it through video not
just text do it through video because
it's easier for me to respond back and
don't do a 50 part video do one or two
videos that you put so I can get back to
you at times when I'm able to check it
and my snap code should be on the video
I think to the bottom bottom of my right
your bottom left I think it's over here
right it's over here click on this to
follow me username is bad david 19 but
this is the pillow we will be using in
all of 2017 and Paul you got to make
sure you clean up all that protein that
you're making a mess with your menu go
over pull up oh my gosh this is just
non-stop with Paul man hey take care
everybody bye-bye